ما هي الاسباب الكامنه وراء اختيار مضيفه
الطيران الاستراليه روزي او المقعد بالصف
الخامس تحديدا الافضل بالطائره اولها
المنظر ممتاز من النافذه حيث يمكنك رؤيه
جزء من جناح الطائره وهو جزء من المدينه
في الخارج هناك مساحه اضافيه لتمديد
القدمين لمزيد من الراحه خاصه اذا كان
الراكب طويلا لا توجد مسؤوليه مخرج
الطوارئ على الراكب في الصف الخامس
والراكب في هذا الصف يستطيع وضع حقيبه
صغيره تحت الكرسي المقابل بسبب المساحه
الاضافيه ويعتبر هذا الصف من اقرب الصفوف
في مخرج الطائره حيث يتم المغادره السريعا
دون اي تاخير ويعتبر من اوائل الصفوف التي
يبدا المضيفون بتقديم الخدمات لهم لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات